why do refugees leave their country
there's no question
[Music]
hello guys my name is muhammad rahima
i'm a refugee from syria
my name is maya gazelle i'm 20 years old
and i'm an aviation engineering student
i'm also a refugee from syria but there
is all sorts of questions floating all
around the internet
lots of clear there
let's start with the first question
so here we go
why do refugees leave their country
refugees leave their countries because
of
danger of prosecution because of danger
of conflict
danger of their lives because of crime
danger as well
but the main point is that when a person
leaves their country
feeling that it's not safe for them to
go back to their country that's what
makes
refugees refugees what our refugee comes
like it's very difficult place
to live like then shelters cold weather
wet weather
but life good as well we made friends
met people they trust you they know who
you are
it's like between we have a difficult
time
and happy time in the same time how
do refugees learn english
i had to learn it myself which was quite
successful like you know i can speak now
english and understand well and write
when i first time arrived to the camp i
never
speak any english i was in a detention
center for
months and a half so i have to get
dictionary from the library there and
like because i get letter from the home
office i have to understand what this
mean
because you have to help yourself in the
detention center
how are refugees treated well that
actually depends on you
i treat very well i me very lovely
people all my life
here in uk but it depends
i only had difficulties being a refugee
when
i first came and wanted to enroll to a
school
it was very difficult actually for me
because i was rejected from three
schools and in college
i still can't understand why would they
turn as
an eager student to study down
hopefully it's easy question
can refugees work in the uk
yeah of course they can work in the uk
but they have to wait uh to get their
refugee status
so when my dad came to the uk he um
it took him about 15 months for his
application to be processed and to move
from an asylum seeker process
to a refugee and during that time
obviously
he was not permitted to work which made
him really really upset
with the uk how you imagined
no i was very disappointed i expected
our neighbors to knock on our door
and give us like a basket basket of
chocolate
you know like a welcome goodies i
expected what i saw in movies and you
marry prince charming or prince harry
but
he's married now and he's got a baby
that's what i expected
what do you miss about your home country
i miss my teddy bears i miss my room
the house that i grew up in the
neighborhood so we used to
walk in the mountains and this was a
fresh air
and lovely is this the smell i still
have it to this moment
but i miss my family they're still there
i miss myself in my home country because
i
changed massively since moving to uk
i had to hopefully one day i back
what is the question you wish people
asked
i wish they asked me if i was okay
what is my dream but i'm not gonna say
it in the camera right here now
i wish people focused more of on who i
am rather than
my background and on my ambitions and
dreams rather than
my past and see you later guys
you